what's up man so what are we doing here
well what we're doing here seems the
fractured featherline family is falling
farther apart
as britney spears's son jaden speaks out
about his and brother preston's strained
relationship with their mom
and brittany she's standing her ground
the boys have decided that
you know they they're they're not seeing
her right now it's been a few months
since they've actually even seen her
they made the decision not to go to her
wedding
in a new interview set to air friday on
itv news daily mail reports
fifteen-year-old jaden tells daphne
barrick why he and preston are taking
space from brit
promising there's no hate and adding
he'd like to see her again someday quote
i 100 think this can be fixed it's just
going to take a lot of time and effort
i just want her to get better mentally
when she gets better i really want to
see her again
a big issue for jaden and preston the
way brit uses social media
[Music]
jaden says he understands social media
helps britt so he doesn't hate her for
it but adds this has gone on for years
and years and years and there's a high
chance that this will never stop but i'm
hoping for me that she will stop i can't
imagine how it feels to be a teenager
having to go to high school
who knows how many people ask them about
it or talk to them about it and i try to
explain to them like you know look
that's
maybe just another way that she
tries to express herself or
but it doesn't take away from the fact
that what it does
to them you know it's it's tough
the teenager also explains why he and
his brother chose to skip britt's june
wedding to samaskari
[Music]
jaden explains she didn't invite the
whole family and then if it was just
going to be me and preston i just don't
see how that situation would have ended
on good terms
still he says he's very happy for the
newlyweds
[Music]
but it didn't take long for news of
jaden's interview to reach brittany she
shared her feelings in a lengthy
instagram post first bringing up her
13-year long conservatorship what she
calls being basically held hostage
they literally killed me
they threw me away that's what i felt
like my family threw me away
the pop star says after over a decade
under her father's watch she hopes one
day her kids can understand why she
likes to be playful on social media she
also speaks to jaden directly telling
him she'll love him and his brother
every day for the rest of her life
quote it deeply saddens me to know his
outcry of saying i wasn't up to his
expectations of a mother and maybe one
day we can meet face to face and talk
about this openly
you